you're a school teacher a maths teacher
who are the over last short peer tom has
become a celebrity how did you manage
that Eddie
look I think I'm as surprised as anyone
else to be honest even now in other
classrooms mass is not perceived to be
fun when did you decide that you can
make mess I knew fairly early on that I
wanted to be a high school teacher but
as to what subject I was going to teach
that was really quiet up to question in
Bush and history were things I enjoyed
very much at school it's not gravitated
towards those but when I reached
university I discovered that there's a
huge critical shortage which was true
then and it's true now in mathematics
education so I somewhat jumped in unsure
of how deep the pool was then I was
getting into it I used to be a school
teacher as well
one thing I also learned you know the
same goes in the media you're in sales
you are selling something to an audience
that's not all that initially very
interested
I remember my school audiences you
really have to work hard to get them
onside well I heard someone compared
once mathematics teachers to people who
are selling a product that people are
don't want to buy but I'm required by
law to pay for and so for me you know
it's a great joy to be able to say look
here's something which you don't miss
maybe have a great expectation and add
this being a wonderful thing but
actually there's a reason we make it
part of your curriculum so Eddy is it
true that they're changing the way math
is being taught in New South Wales as a
consequence of your success look I'd
probably say the most simplest to
recognize that is no because in some
ways you know I've been given this new
very flowery title which is the leader
of innovative practice in mathematics
which is very kind but to be honest the
the thing that I feel I'm most getting
across it's not innovation so much as
rediscovering ancient techniques that
are making sense of what children don't
understand struggle with understanding
but there's a story and it is a personal
side to mathematic mathematics is for
everyone I know that a lot of people and
including
self when I was younger felt like
mathematics is something that's for for
special people you've got a gift with
numbers you can see patterns you can
just do a multiplication a huge numbers
just like that one wild and wacky
question which comes from a little bit
of science I guess there's a book called
outliers by Malcolm Gladwell I do know
nothing he argued was he remains just
carried someone else's cockamamie theory
that in the south of China because of
the 24/7 working in the rice paddy that
there is this great work ethic but the
North Face plant the weight and they're
lazy they wait for the wit to grow what
did you think when you came across that
usual sweeping generalizations
especially being someone who was born in
Australia I think that there there is
something that is true there in that
mathematics is a practical subject is it
just like music or a sport in that you
gain skill in it by doing it it's
something that I see all the time as a
parent myself and parents I interact
with that there are often two sorts of
attitudes when you come to water a
subject or even a sport or an
extracurricular activity you people say
oh look just just going through them try
them out and find the one that finally
you enjoy that you're really good at you
have a natural flair for yeah and then
there's another approach which is to say
well look of course you're not gonna be
very good at basketball we start keep
going 10,000 hours to mastery is what
they say and so that's a very different
tack yeah you're pretty awful to married
you're slow if you're uncoordinated
but persist and we might actually
develop some skill and when when you get
to talk to a young person who's
struggling with math you starting to see
that they're just on you enjoy what
you're doing is it is it the easy to
just tell that story to them absolutely
I mean one of the most important quotes
to me as mathematician is that
mathematicians are not people who find
mathematics easy they are the ones who
enjoy how hard it is and any
professional athlete can you know
identify with that that you know it's
just it's immense it's blood sweat and
tears but in fact leaning into that and
persevering through it is what makes an
athlete and it's what makes a
mathematician I hate to say this I do I
think you're gonna grow into a very
exceptional well person
thanks for joining us on Switzer it's a
pleasure thank you so much